all right Howard here's something that's
going to blow your mind
blow my mind who's the highest-paid
actor in television today do you know
television let me see I love that ray
Donovan he's not highest-paid let me
think the highest-paid actor so he's on
a TV series I'm gonna make an educated
guess here and say somebody from that
show on CBS with the Nerds
Big Bang someone from Big Bang Theory
yes you would be correct oh look at me
because that is I guess the high rated
series around and it's been around for a
very long time and this is excuse me
Gary this is their last season why is it
their last season with you Gary wants to
do the show I could I'll sit back excuse
me I want to do before why is it why is
it Robin because Jim Parsons who is one
of the actors on the show is considered
essential to the show and he has turned
down an offer from CBS for 50 million
dollars excuse me both let me say that
Gary loves me you love to know why did
it show go ahead you can talk about it
now dear diary today I hijacked the show
and did the show with Robin even though
Howard is there
[Music]
[Applause]
their diamond today Robin got in the way
of me talking about Big Bang field I
knew the answer and she wouldn't let me
blurt it out
do you know why he's quitting Gary yes I
do you know what said I'm an expert in
Big Bang Theory I like being that guy
are you [ __ ] put me on with all the
interruptions yeah alright let's shut up
it's a matter with you